I debated Patrick Dineen last year where
he claimed that there's a liberal
tyranny this is a so-called woke
dominance of American culture and it's
just a wild exaggeration yeah I think
that contemporary America is one of the
freest societies that's ever lived the
only areas where you get this kind of
uniformity of liberal thought on a
restricted set of basically civil rights
issues having to do with race ethnicity
gender sexual orientation and that
dominance is true only in certain kind
of elite spaces like universities
Hollywood the Arts and so forth and
there I think there is a bit of a
problem because a lot of progressive
identity politics tends to get pretty
intolerant that's a left-wing threat to
to liberalism but Patrick Dineen then
goes from that to saying we live in a
total tyranny no difference between us
and China or Russia it's absurd it's
just absurd